I'm soon going to enjoy the full-time
trading and expand my business partly
data is the most important factor to be
successful there I plan to use the
professional certificate program in data
science to make that happen
hey I'm Ali handy I live in Iran and I'm
a civil engineer professional I run my
own business by the name of ARG CMO
my business deals with providing
consultancy in the construction sector
and selling artificial stones and black
components I juggle a few jobs to
sustain my business
I do some trading and I teach at the
local University as a part-time civil
engineering instructor though I'm a
scholar and I have published many
articles on civil engineering now when I
look at them I feel that if I knew data
science at that time many things would
be different I wanted to enhance my
knowledge for which I decided to take
course insane I chose to learn scores
because of this Association before the
university I doubt it's not just a good
opportunity to learn data science but
also gain a certification from a highly
reputed University
simpler and also provide again with some
complementary courses in Python and
agile which I think will be really
helpful in the Line run I plan to use
these learnings to expand my business
and make it profitable at the University
we have to deal with a lot of projects
that include a lot of data I think this
course will help me solve those problems
more rationally it will help me build my
personal brand as a data scientist too
right now they spend my time in trading
about five hours a day in scalping mode
with my own strategy but soon I will
then change the trading algorithms which
are in dire need of data analysis I'm
happy that I'm Paving the road the
success and removing obstacles in my way
by upskilling myself